harvest time at this coffee plantation
in Sumatra and it's plentiful farmers
would normally celebrate but not this
year they are the world's third-largest
growers of the robusta variety of coffee
beans but the market price they are
fetching is at an eight-year low if the
price of coffee stays like this we can't
continue
we might not attend our plantations
anymore because we can't afford
fertilizer we don't have enough money to
pay our workers in my case I still have
to pay for my son's high school robusta
is used mainly in instant coffee and
demand has been increasing but prices
have dropped this year because of the
success of the two largest producers
Brasil and Vietnam while Indonesian
farmers struggle to make money there's a
growing demand domestically as more
Indonesians get a taste for what they
produce growing affluence and
urbanization are driving the rise of the
so called coffee lifestyle and many more
coffee shops are opening up some are
part of a chain that others like this
one in Jakarta are independent I come
here two or three times a week the price
of coffee for what I get is well worth
it
not cheap but not too expensive
Indonesia is one of the top five fastest
growing coffee retail markets and has
the lowest coffee consumption per person
in Southeast Asia so there's plenty of
room for growth there's so much
confidence in the industry that one
coffee chain received twenty eight
million dollars from venture capital
firms in the past year for its expansion
plans the local market can absorb a
large amount of domestically grown
coffee only 30 percent of coffee grown
here is exported but if the price of
coffee keeps dropping farmers will stop
planting coffee and that would be a huge
loss for everyone demand from Indonesia
coffee drinkers has so far helped
cushion the blow from falling export
prices back at his plantation Guiana is
hopeful the price of coffee beans will
recover in the meantime
he's planted other crops just in case
Florence lui al Jazeera Jakarta